[Music]
the arson attack in the town of sorting
and in 1993 was one of the worst cases
of xenophobic violence in post-war
Germany and it triggered a huge response
Tim quartz bug you're the city's current
mayor I'd like to talk to you about what
happened back then and what it can teach
us today I quote 25 years ago four
neo-nazis four young men
set fire to the house of a family with
Turkish roots named Kench five people
were killed seventeen injured some
critically do you remember that day been
answering your borland I was born and
grew up in Seoul again in 1993 I was 15
man as soon as we heard what happened my
parents and I went to the site of the
attack the very same day only cup bigot
star Vivian
I shall never forget the image of that
old half-timbered house with the roof
gone except for the toys that house full
from him that I suspect is true for many
people in zolina and then swear it
affected my thoughts and my feelings
deeply I clearly remember a feeling of
total shock and disbelief it was four
youngsters about the same age as some of
the victims in me I went to school I was
already a student representative but at
that moment I thought I really have to
get involved and change things and
momentum boy did I have a domestic anger
it was also a nun yeah you were active
in a Catholic youth group and you saw
that young men your own age between 16
and 23 were capable of such a barbaric
act did you talk about this with your
friends and at least total of good we
were all totally upset the whole town
was how could something like that happy
here we always thought of Zhu Ling and
as friendly colorful and multicultural
multi-cut who will not know there was a
group like that in zoning
I don't think the town was or is a
bastion of the extreme right there is no
data to support that nonetheless there
was a far-right movement and why didn't
we notice why do you think I think it
has to do with the nature of the public
debate at the time there was a lot of
emotion and agitation like there is
again today under that dreadful slogan
the boat is full there had been a debate
in Parliament three days earlier about
changing the law and asylum whenever
there are such domain debates people
don't always think clearly in my
Catholic youth group we held a special
event during a service we had built a
house out of papier mache and re-enacted
what had happened we had someone come in
and set it on fire that caused a huge
commotion in the congregation what we
had not realised the head of time is
that the smoke and the soot would hang
in the air throughout the service that's
another image I will never forget why
had we not seen what was brewing that
something was in the air why haven't we
faced it earlier these are powerful
images that will always stay with me how
did the attack change during it was
always known as the center of the
cutlery industry and then certainly as a
bastion of the extreme right it is still
more the capital of cutlery at the time
then and now every year around May the
29th the attack is in everybody's mind
here but the rest of the world still
associate sizzling and with cutlery as
the people of zoning and two things will
always stick in their mind first they
still can't believe it really happened
to this day it remains inconceivable
second they still can't get their heads
around what happened in the days after
the attack our town was abused by
outsiders far-right Germans and also
far-right Turks and they trashed the
town centre
even Turkish and Sina when how long's
were instructing many here still look
back on those days in 1993 with a sense
of anxiety the rightists and anarchists
and the ultra-nationalist Turkish gray
wolves were very active at the time and
they were all lined up against the
people of Zoning it was a dreadful mood
in the country after the other attacks
in Hoyas vera Rostock and moon and then
there was this terrible unimaginable
attack here in zulan with five dead if I
think the groups of outsiders who came
here wanted to take it out on the
Germans I would say they did not
distinguish very clearly who was to
blame and who wasn't
local people started all kinds of
projects charitable foundations
donations spending nights with immigrant
families who felt frightened the display
of solidarity was fantastic and
spontaneous hauling and may have come to
stand for something horrible but one
needs to take a closer look and
acknowledge the positive things the
people here did soling and mustn't be
seen merely as a symbol for the negative
side of German society as a whole
you said the attack was one reason you
became politically active
PolitiFact it's when you know they were
men yes I was standing in front of the
house and then later when we talked
about it I said this cannot be we have
to stand up and do something and as fate
would have it I am now mayor of my
hometown which is not something I had
ever expected
I realized back then that democracy and
pluralism cannot be taken for granted in
a city or state that's the Democratic
democracy is not about saying it is the
responsibility of this group or that to
make sure things go well the politicians
the media or whoever each one of us must
assume responsibility every day anew
what conclusions have you drawn from the
events of 1993 what is it that drives
xenophobia I'm sure you thought about
that a lot
and exits almost would fear and
ignorance when we are in a lack of
contact and a lack of dialogue when
people don't know anything about each
other and don't express clearly what
they find troubling in the other bogus
celebrations of togetherness we need to
be honest address issues and thrash them
out an example just recently the Turkish
Foreign Minister was here on a visit
which triggered a very heated debate and
just to be clear I have huge issues with
the Turkish government and the way it's
acting right now no question but the
answer can never be that we ceased to
engage in dialogue ostracizing the other
side and ceasing to listen is not the
solution now more than ever we need to
talk to each other because if we don't
all these prejudices will just grow
having no interaction actually feeds the
sense of resentment I believe that the
German government needs to take action
in response to the increasingly strident
rhetoric coming from Ankara but those
who think that the entrance of the
far-right AFD party into the German
parliament is good because the AFP
expresses its criticism clearly are
sadly mistaken the AF DS language of
hatred will not make anything better
soaring in his home to a large immigrant
population third of the school children
have foreign roots the far-right
populist AFD party won almost 10 percent
of the vote here at the last general
election is xenophobia on the rise in
zoning and once again it's not resulting
in problem but still of course I wasn't
trying to avoid the question but let's
be clear this is not just a problem for
Rowling and it's a problem for the whole
of our society the influx of refugees in
2015 posed a challenge to the whole of
Germany but you know hauling and never
had dozens of refugees shelters right
from the start I said to our people
don't let's banish these refugees to
certain areas what we need is hundreds
of private apartments
if neighbors can take in new neighbors
you have integration working and right
from the first day and it worked we as a
city we as a country we're not at all
prepared for an influx of over a million
refugees and without the great response
shown by the people of Zoar lien we as a
city would never have coped and I think
that is the message from Solon
we are more sensitive than others and we
are more active in integrating the
refugees that have come we still need to
face the challenges of our society just
like other cities and regions but I
think other cities need to re-engage
with this signal we can't pretend that
the battle against the far-right is over
incisions at all the perpetrators are
now free Maynard again lost two children
two grandchildren and Denise but she
says there's no hatred in her heart and
she continues to live in sorting I asked
myself whether I could do that and
decided I couldn't could you then
[ __ ] wait you are absolutely right
and I think it's important to make it
clear to our viewers what actually
happened here two of the five victims
were just children er you know I have
two sons and I don't know how I'd react
if someone even hurt them slightly just
the thought that something could happen
to my children is so painful and then
you think about this ordinary woman meth
lewd again and yes I know some people
question why she can't speak German
after all these years when I stand in
front of this woman
I am so humbled I'm so grateful no one
has the right to accuse her of anything
just hours after her children
grandchildren and niece were killed she
somehow found the strength to stand up
and call for peace and reconciliation
using an impressive language of the
heart she doesn't use intellectual words
but the authentic words of a mother
it goes so deep and all of us need to be
deeply grateful to Mehmood against a
scientist
Hamilton mr. quartz Park we always
finish our interviews with three
sentences I'd like you to complete for
the benefit of social cohesion and
Zoning and I would like for each person
every day to realize for themselves that
they have a responsibility towards
others and for all time I want my
children to grow up in a Germany that
against that takes it for granted that
people have different faiths come from
different countries love in different
ways and sees that as an enrichment
because we are a rich and great country
but as a practicing Catholic and I draw
strength from my faith knowing there is
always hope of something new in the
darkest hour you can have hope because
life continues whether here or in
eternity Jim quartz Wow thank you thank
you